프로그래밍 모델은 소프트웨어가 어떻게 구조화되고
실행되는지를 정의하는 기본 명세야
개발자들이 알고리즘을 표현할 수 있는 프레임워크를 제공하고
코드를 구성할 수 있게 해줘
종종 하드웨어나 실행 환경의 저수준 세부 사항을 추상화해서
숨겨주지
다양한 모델들은 서로 다른 유형의 문제와
하드웨어에 적합하게 설계되어 있어
다양한 수준의 추상화를
제공하지. 이 챕터에서는
양자 및 고전 프로그래밍 모델을 살펴보고
이를 결합해서 알고리즘을 실행하는 방법을 알아볼 거야
자
양자 컴퓨터의 프로그래밍 모델부터 시작해볼게
양자 컴퓨터의 기본 프로그래밍 모델 중 하나는
거의 모든 양자 개발자에게 친숙한
quantum circuit이야. 여기선
quantum circuit의 세부 사항에 대해선
깊이 들어가지 않을 거야. Joan Waters의 강의를 포함해
이미 훌륭한 자료들이 많이 있거든
circuit은 qubit을 나타내는
와이어라고 불리는 선들의 집합과
양자 상태에 대한 연산을 나타내는 gate들,
그리고 측정 집합으로 구성돼
또 다른 중요한 프로그래밍 모델 개념은
프리미티브야
이 프리미티브들은 사용자가 양자 컴퓨터로
수행하려는 가장 일반적인 작업들을 나타내
현재 두 가지 프리미티브가 있어
Sampler와 Estimator야. Sampler는 quantum circuit으로
준비된 상태를 샘플링할 수 있게 해주고
Estimator는 네 quantum
circuit으로 준비된 상태의 시스템에 대한 관측값의 기댓값을
추정할 수 있게 해줘. 마지막으로 이 섹션에서
얘기할 개념은
transpilation이야. transpilation은
주어진 입력 circuit을 특정 양자
장치의 토폴로지에 맞게
재작성하는 과정이야
노이즈가 있는 양자 컴퓨터에서 실행하기 위해
고전 컴파일러와 유사하게
transpilation 루틴은 패스 집합을 적용해
circuit의 구조를 점진적으로 변환해
이제 고전 프로그래밍 모델에 대해 얘기해보자
고전 컴퓨터를 위한 프로그래밍 모델은
굉장히 많아
하지만 이 챕터에서는 두 가지에 집중할 거야
가장 인기 있는 병렬 프로그래밍과
태스크 워크플로우야. 이 두 모델을
양자 프로그래밍 모델과 결합하면
어떤 복잡성의 하이브리드
양자-고전 워크플로우도 표현할 수 있어
병렬 프로그래밍 모델은
프로그램을 동시에 실행할 수 있는 문제들로
나눠. 병렬 프로그래밍에는 두 가지 주요 패러다임이 있어
공유 메모리 병렬처리와 분산 메모리 병렬처리야
여기서 우리 목적에 맞게 분산 메모리 모델에 집중해보자
분산 메모리 모델은
별도의 코어에서 독립적인 프로세스를
사용하거나 각 프로세스가 자체 메모리를 갖는 노드를 사용해
그리고 통신은 메시지 패싱을 통해 이루어져. 알아두면 유용한
개념들이 몇 가지 있어
첫 번째는 프로세스야
프로그램의 독립적인 인스턴스로
별도의 코어에서 실행돼
그리고 rank는 프로세스의 고유 식별자야
그 다음에는 단일 프로그램
다중 데이터 추상화 모델이 있어
이건 추상화 모델이야
프로그램의 단일 인스턴스가
여러 노드에 배포되는 연산을 위한
즉 소스 코드는 동일하지만
각 노드의 데이터는 달라
병렬 프로그래밍 모델에서 실행은
다음과 같은 방식으로 이루어져
단일 프로그램이 여러 노드에 배포되고
여러 병렬 프로세스를 시작해
프로그램의 제어 흐름은 rank에 의해 결정돼
즉 프로세스의 식별자에 의해서
그리고 통신은
메시지 패싱을 통해 이루어져
태스크 워크플로우 프로그래밍 모델은
연산을 그래프 또는 DAG로 추상화해
그래프의 각 노드는 특정 태스크나
작업이고 엣지는 데이터 의존성과
순서를 나타내. 예시는 문서에서 찾아볼 수 있어
결국 양자 컴퓨팅에서 항상 얘기하는 그 시퀀스도
맵핑, 최적화,
실행, 후처리는
태스크 워크플로우 프로그래밍 모델이야
모든 태스크가 파이프라인에서 순서대로
하나씩 실행되지
하지만 태스크 워크플로우를 사용하면
순차 실행 순서에 얽매이지 않아도 되고
태스크를 병렬로 실행할 수도 있어
각 태스크나 워크플로우는 독립적인 전체 병렬 작업이 될 수 있어
그러니까 이 모델들을 섞어서
조합하면 어떤 알고리즘이든
어떤 복잡성도 표현할 수 있어.
배운 개념들을 코드에 적용해보자
먼저 병렬 프로그래밍 패러다임을 사용해서 간단한 hello world를 실행해볼게
병렬 프로그래밍 패러다임으로
Open MPI를 사용할 거야
MPI 프로토콜의 구현체인데
병렬 프로그래밍에서 메시지 패싱의
표준이야
먼저 프로그램 코드가 필요해
여기서 mpi4py를 사용하는데
Python 바인딩이야
MPI를 위한 것이고, 여기서 rank를 사용해 프로그램의
제어 흐름을 결정하는 걸 볼 수 있어
자 이제 제출 스크립트를 확인해보자.
두 개의 노드를 사용할 거야
노멀 파티션에서 노드당 하나의 태스크
프로그램을 실행해보자. 잠깐 기다리면
작업 결과를 확인할 수 있어
보다시피 프로그램의 로그 출력이 나왔어
두 개의 노드와 두 개의 프로세스를 사용했고
rank로 식별돼
여기 출력에서 볼 수 있듯이
rank 0과 rank 1이 사용되어 결정하지
프로그램의 제어 흐름을
보다시피 rank 0 프로세스가
rank 1 프로세스로 페이로드를 보냈고
rank 1 프로세스가 수신했어
이제 태스크 워크플로우에 대해서도 얘기해보자
워크로드 관리 시스템이라고 불리는
도구들이 있어. 이 도구들은 복잡한 워크플로우를
실행하기 위해 특별히 설계됐어
하지만 너무 복잡하게 만들지 않으려고 Slurm의
내장 의존성 기능을 사용해서
이런 계산 그룹들을 구성해볼 거야
먼저 워크플로우의 각 태스크가
준비되어 있어야 해. 코드는 동일한데
이 태스크들 각각을
맵핑, 최적화, 실행,
후처리를 별도 단계로 갖는 장점은
각 태스크마다 고유한 리소스 요구사항을
지정할 수 있다는 거야. 예를 들어 맵핑, 최적화,
후처리는
양자 리소스에
접근할 필요가 없어. 그래서 클래식 파티션에서 실행할 수 있어.
하지만 실행 태스크는
양자 리소스가 필요해. 그래서 양자
파티션에서 실행할 거야.
이제 Slurm의 의존성 기능을 사용해서 태스크들을
워크플로우로 연결해보자.
보다시피 아직 실행 중이야
--parsable 플래그와 함께 sbatch 명령을 실행하면
job ID를 반환해줘
그러면 이 job ID를
다른 태스크의 의존성으로 전달할 수 있어
보다시피 의존성이 있는
워크플로우에서 작업들을 실행하고 있어
전체 워크플로우가 완료되면 결과를 확인할 수 있어.
그리고 보다시피 기댓값 결과가 나왔어.
각 단계의 모든
결과도 확인할 수 있어.
여기에 다 있어.
이걸로 프로그래밍 모델 섹션은 끝이야
다음 챕터에서는 고급
알고리즘에 대해 얘기할 거야